[Música]
[Aplausos]
con las tardes
en esos momentos
e intencionada de eso porque mi corazón
hace
así fuerte así que se para entender un
poco otra emoción
yo les vengo a hablar acá de una idea
un ideal que está compuesto por ideas
pero que también dice en real compresión
en experiencias personales profesional
ideas que se fueran acumulando por
brotes
generativos
previa y socio necesito contarles un
poco desde que yo baso ve al mundo y
entienda que es una manera de barrio no
es la verdad
creo que estamos viviendo el mundo que
es volátil e incierto imprevisible
complejo que nos abruma muchas veces
un mundo que está en permanente cambio
de transformación a grandes velocidades
un mundo en el que ha habido grandes
avances en derechos humanos donde la
mujer está siendo contrabandista de una
agenda para ser igualada en derechos
ellos se llama siglo
un mundo en el que ha habido una agenda
que incluye minorías y se puso en esa
agenda el debate de la identidad de
género
pero también es un mundo que sigue
siendo injusto desigual con grandes
varillas sociales y humanitarias
un botón permanente transformación
tecnológica tanto es así que el cerebro
humano muchas veces ante esa oferta
tecnológica no puede adaptar y asimilar
los chicos que actualmente están
estudiando y creciendo van a trabajar en
un futuro cercano en profesiones y
oficios que aún no han sido creadas
en el medio de esto este abrumante mundo
que también es divina aunque estamos las
personas
los seres humanos
y yo ve aquí en las personas un recurso
que nos puede ayudar a crear comunidades
para hacer propuestas de un mundo más
igualitario y está el recurso emocional
ninguna tecnología ningún robots una
máquina inteligencia artificial va a
reemplazar jamás desde mi punto de vista
a las emociones humanas
las emociones humanas que también si la
tomamos como cuestiones singulares
es donde hay valor se han preguntado a
ustedes cuál es el talento
y cuál es la capacidad y la habilidad
que los hace únicos
porque es importante saberlo para poder
contarlo comunicarlo y juntarnos con
otros que tienen otras habilidades y
talentos y crear comunidades
de iguales y diversas
comunidad de vecinos en tratativas
especialidades sociales
para ir haciendo aportes para que este
mundo que habitamos sea mejor
hable de lo singular ahora quiero
pedirles que levanten la mano quienes
son seres humanos con emociones
levanten la mano ahora quiénes son
hijos e hijas
esto es los segundos menos igual
todos venimos de una familia
de un sistema familiar que además
habitan los sistemas social y cultural
un sistema familiar cultural y social
que tiene reglas mandatos creencias y
paradigmas
cuando nosotros nacemos es el sistema
empieza a operar ya describir en nuestra
hoja de vida los 15 aceptados y los
menos aceptados lo que está bien y lo
que está mal
qué pasa entonces cuando transitamos la
educación primaria o secundaria en mi
caso también la educación católica a
través del catecismo y empezamos a
encontrarnos con algunas incoherencias
de lo que nos dicen que tenemos que
estar
yo recuerdo que ni catequista con mucho
amor y convicción de dogma y entienda
este mes en una crítica en juicio de
valor a la región me contaba la idea de
familia
y yo llego a mi casa de vivir una
experiencia diametralmente opuesta
muchas veces
entonces
me decía alguien está mintiendo
por supuesto que dejé enojarme con el
catequista
porque necesitamos pertenecer al sistema
familiar todos los seres humanos
necesitamos que nos quieran que nos
acepten que nos respeten los valores que
nos miremos inclusión
son necesidades básicas del ser humano
ese fue el primer registro de
incoherencia e inconsistencia
para poder incorporar cosas nuevas
tenemos que aprender a desaprender
porque si no siempre seguimos caminando
la misma dirección si nos van a decir
siempre que tenemos que ser cuando por
ahí lo que sentimos si deseamos es otra
cosa
desaprender es un proceso de decisión
personal que muchas veces es muy
doloroso pero créanme a la vez de mucha
expansión
como des aprendí desde la experiencia
porque puedes comenzar y tener todos los
posgrados
pero si no lo vivencias te lo pasaste
por el cuerpo no hay real aprendizaje
recuerdo a los siete años escuchar una
conversación familiar que quizás no
tenía que haber escuchado si mi papá
hablaba con mi madre y unos parientes
que habían visitado la familia y estaban
haciendo como una reflexión sobre
ciertos comportamientos y conductas mías
el papá le dijo mamá si sigue estando
abajo tu posición es de tu identidad y
la abuela lo vas a hacer marca
eso se instalan y como el mandato mucha
suerte de vida y de honrar que eso no
tenía que estar
entre los 7 y los 17 años yo hice todo
lo que estuvo a mi alcance para ser el
mejor hijo el mejor estudiante
el mejor hermano
pero aún no puede escapar el equino
a los 17 años coincidiendo con vida de
concordia buenos aires a estudiar pero
sin saber a encontrarme conmigo mismo
entonces ahí empecé un proceso de
autoconocimiento profundo
que también es una decisión personal si
uno sabe quién es para que esta
mentalidad es muy difícil ser aporte de
algo
pero también sé que jugaba 6 mi deseo mi
destino o ser una vergüenza
con los años aprendí que eso que me dijo
mi padre lo hacía desde el amor porque
los padres y la gente que nos quiere
siempre quiere lo mejor para nosotros lo
que pasa que habitualmente no nos
preguntan si eso que ellos quieren es lo
que nosotras necesitamos
pero ahora mi padre porque aún ve mi
vida decidí seguir
los valores de diversidad e inclusión
son algo que no negocio
y es donde yo desde lugares de liderazgo
dirección
puedo llevar para que otras personas
tengan otras experiencias de vida
distintas al escribir
muchas veces me quise bajar de este
mundo
como decía mafalda para el mundo que
quiere bajar lo que pasa que es la única
vida que tenemos
y la única certeza con la que nacemos en
la que vamos a morir entonces cómo vamos
a vivirla
además hay dos opciones mirar el mundo y
fijarme o mirar el mundo y tomar acción
e involucrarme para hacer
transformaciones pero no desde una
utopía de cambiar el mundo sino desde el
metro cuadrado de acción de cada uno de
nosotros
también este cambio de transformación
personal incluida dimensión del alma
porque estamos educados actualmente en
el paradigma racionalista muchas veces
la razón nos impide conectar con esa
esencia con quien hace con nosotros y la
mano está siempre sabe está esperando
que haya una zapada a que le demos lugar
y cuando logramos conectar hay una
fuerza que se conecta y nos impulsa
hacia el destino que tenemos
quiero contarles que parte de este
camino no pude transitar el tránsito en
ambientes empresariales porque cuando yo
estudiaba decía que yo quería llevar
esto a las empresas
no es fácil incluir la dimensión de la
diversidad la inclusión y del alma en
las empresas
porque habitualmente aparece el
cuestionamiento de que acá estamos para
hacer negocios y ser rentables ya una
cuestión más yo lo que cuestiona que
abordaje tenemos respecto a las personas
por eso el área no se llama recursos
humanos con el equipo le pusimos
desarrollo humano porque somos humanos
el desarrollo permanente que tenemos
sueños proyectos queremos progresar
necesitamos que nos quieran que nos
miran que nos valida y respeten
por nuestra identidad y no porque el
otro quiere que sean sus hijos
créanme que desde que implementamos hace
4 años esta filosofía y política de
gestión todos los años las mediciones
que hacemos son altamente positivas
porque todas las personas necesitamos
sentirnos en ambientes saludables ser
felices
y que nos respeten por nuestras
capacidades y no por nuestras elecciones
con nuestras etiquetas
quiero terminar con el ideal de mi frase
y tiene que ver con liderazgo
el desafío más importante que tenemos es
lideramos a nosotros mismos
si no aprendemos a registrar cómo opera
más emociones en nosotros
vamos a estar siempre siendo reactivos
para no ser vergüenza por ejemplo
hay que aprender a liderar la palabra y
poner en palabras lo que no podemos
decir porque lo que no se dice no se
sabe lo que no se sabe
no se identifican
liderar para toda liderar a otras
personas liderar la transformación
personal para poder transformar a otros
y que otros líderes se desarrollen en
este sentido hay empresas que ya tienen
gerencias de felicidad no porque es una
moda sino porque todos queremos ser
felices créanme que las personas cuando
nos miran con estas capacidades y la
posibilidad de desarrollo damos lo mejor
de nosotros mismos
para que es muy importante la mirada le
doy mucha importancia está comprobado
que un bebé admirado por su madre de los
primeros horas
de nacimiento tiene altamente
probabilidades de tener problemas de
desarrollo emocional intelectual porque
la mirada nos configura y nos interpela
sin embargo pasamos más tiempo mirando
la pantalla del celular que mirándose
ante los ojos
hay una publicación en la red social
tiene su celular para que me toques y
miremos tiempo
yo los invito por favor a que miren aquí
tienen al costado suyo
un segundo si lo conocen le dicen
gracias
si no se dicen muchas cosas
ampliada mirada nos permite no mirar la
línea recta sino mirar más circular
simplemente porque los ojos son redondos
porque el mundo es redondo y porque nos
perdemos a veces la posibilidad de que
alguien que tenemos al lado de enfrente
los aportes algo para cambiar los
anteojos como si miramos el mundo yo soy
producto de esa mirada de amor pero
también porque hubieron personas en mi
camino de vida que me miraron vivieron
mis recursos y me habilitar la
oportunidades para hacer lo que quiero
ser y desarrollarme profesionalmente
decía el principito
caminando línea recta no puede uno
llegar muy lejos
si yo no hubiese podido mirar más en
círculo y dar vuelta esta emoción de la
vergüenza
no podría seguramente estar parado acá
hablando frente a ustedes
yo los invito entonces a ponernos en
acción
a transformarnos es de desaprender lo
que ya no sirve el mundo está cambiando
necesitamos trabajar la inteligencia
emocional
al servicio por supuesto de la vida de
la razón yo decidió honrar mi vida y
agradecer a mis padres por esa vida dada
porque si eso no se hubiera encontrado
yo no estaría equivocado
los invito a ponerse en acción a través
de la transformación pero no desde la
utopía de cambiar el mundo sino desde el
metro cuadrado de acción de cada uno de
ustedes como es decir conexión muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]